before video begins let me show you guys
my setup as you guys know I'm a huge fan
of Opera GX even though it's technically
I should tell you how much I love it I
see my friends not use Opera GX and I'd
silently judge them forever while other
browsers lets you change your background
Opera lets you fully customize
everything they have a ton of cool
themes and live animated backgrounds
they got a ton of Japanese live ones
anime Attack on Titan Hunter Hunter
Naruto one piece and if you use the link
in the description you get my Japanese
style live one as well looking nice it
also integrates with my keyboard and
mouse setup so whatever I click on it
automatically changes the color on it
that's pretty cool speaking of anime
they have a pop-out feature so whatever
you're watching you can move around
resize switch to monitors it's easy and
it works seamlessly if you use my link
in the description to download Opera GX
and reinstall it if you have it of
course which you do of course you get a
new DX Corner update that lets you see
all my latest uploads you know YouTube
likes to hide upload sometimes so it's a
great way to keep track thank you while
other browsers just bombard with a bunch
of clickbait that's super annoying and
no one wants to see that [ __ ] Opera GX
actually gives you updates on games new
releases and different genres I found a
ton of great games through GX corner
it's honestly so good I always recommend
downloading Opera GX on your mobile it
gives you the feature if you're watching
anything just hit the continue watching
button scan it with your phone and
you're on your way baby you can also
send files through your phone in your
computer and vice versa really easily
with my flow I also find that process to
be so awkward the email do you upload my
flow boom it's a seamless it's easy
Opera just has a ton of great features
like that they keep adding them as well
which is why I like it so much it's a
genuinely great browser I I think it
it's 100 the best one any opinion is
wrong other than that use my link to
download it even if you already have it
installed reinstall it get the new
wallpaper and get the new features and
yeah thank you Opera for sponsoring this
video I am inakihabara on the hunt for
some gacha gotcha I'm gonna find every
single one and buy every single one no
matter what it costs my name is beauty
Pat let's do this
foreign
capsules with a random toy inside you
put in money in the machine and a random
gacha from the series comes out what
started as a fun little toy for Japanese
kids has now divulged into fried
construction equipment corn wedding
rings photos of people not smiling and
Godzilla politicians but which gacha is
the best ganja I will spend all the
money I have to find the best one there
is
[Music]
all right we found our first plant we
got some good stuff here
construction man
storage
man with balls on his face pickup truck
oh this is great a gas tank who doesn't
want that climbing wall all right I
guess we gotta get started
again originally they cost 10 yen
apparently they started in 1965.
you have all this selection of stuff
that you can get and it's completely
random it's not gambling for kids you
know good old fun
how cool they've shown what it is all
right I'm gonna stock this whole bag up
we're gonna be here forever emergency
two at the same time
animal Jazz too so good that they added
another one
all right I'm gonna open them at home
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got every single one I feel like a
madman
let's go back and unbox these
I got them all every single gotcha I
gotcha I want to pour it all over the
like but it's just gonna go on the floor
okay you're gonna have to live without
me doing that
these are always such a pain in the ass
to open
they put tape on it
beautiful
what is it
oh these were expensive these were 500
yen it's a warning for the train coming
if they're all like this
and it's gonna take forever
okay it's battery driven that's kind of
cool
first we enter this
and this they go with this
it's gonna be huge oh so depending on
which one I get
I can change the traffic lights that's
exciting I got the traffic lights that
go on the side
it's got a little speaker
then this boy's big
ah no no no no no no I built gunpla okay
I should be able to do this
icky thinks I have food I don't have
food this is a construction very serious
okay I built it
all right guys so you ready
oh wait
who wouldn't want to hear that sound
Jesus Christ okay I mean you get a lot
for your buck uh it looks what it is
which is always good I was hoping it
would move so I'm a little disappointed
I'm raiding that I want and it took way
too long to build easy two out of five
oh okay I remember buying this climbing
walls
I think there were about 200 or 300 Yen
you get the wall and the climbing girl
wow I rate this one out of five maybe I
got more of these so maybe you know if I
keep building it it'll be cool oh here
we go I already have another one I will
recycle these don't worry environment
nerds
okay so this should go like that
okay oh this guy's doing crazy [ __ ]
all right it's looking it's looking cool
no
[Music]
no God damn stop the tape
uh
this is my favorite uh Ramen or like
noodles instant noodles this one I think
it's Chinese actually I'm not entirely
sure don't quote me on that but it's so
spicy and so good and I didn't get it
damn it
I wanted a keychain of that so bad I
will have to go back this is definitely
one of those where like they could have
just added that one because that's the
one Everyone likes
and that would have been cool I would
have liked to have that but I don't
instead I have this zero out of five
this is not looking great actually it
didn't have tape so I will give it one
out of five yeah I think it's Bandai
that doesn't with the tape I appreciate
that okay so this is uh School uh
utensils I guess I got the backpack I
find it interesting how in Asian
countries I mean at least in Japan every
single child has this type of backpack
and it's just like the ultimate
conformity in as a as a young student
like how dare you have another kind of
backpack you are not one of us leave I
don't know the history or why it's like
that I just find it interesting that
everyone has the same back pain
no tape
but I still can't get it open without a
knife what is this this looks cool oh
yes
[Music]
this is one of the last ones I got it's
a gotcha asagacha
but it's also
an hourglass
wait it's leaking
is it supposed to be leaking I feel like
it shouldn't leak
what the hell is it doing there it's
supposed to be in The Hourglass no so
it's five minutes
all right kind of cool but I think it's
broken
one I'm not impressed by the gotcha cons
you don't need to put tape on these it
already has the closing thing there's no
need who does that
put tape on it I learned a lot actually
and I will share my wisdom that I gain
from making this video as we go what is
this oh these were sensor bars
I was very confused
okay this feels very Japanese like kind
of goofy and silly haha but uh it's
literally just a leaf
so if you have like a lewd gotcha I
suppose you can have this when people
come over who are a bit sensitive to
that kind of thing
uh not fun on its own I actually hate it
zero and one one now it had tape zero
for no reason look at this nope okay
let's have a little bit of tape it does
have tape I take it Bang
oh my God they're so hard to open how
did the Japanese do it
[Applause]
this is an expensive one because it's
big I think this is 500 yen no it wasn't
it was 300 I remember it it's a pickup
truck
and it works wow oh even the thing comes
off I can put stuff in there okay that's
not bad these are the ones I could have
gotten but I guess I got the silver one
uh one out of five
I am a harsh critic will you want me to
lie to you I never hey
oh this is cute I think I got this for
Marzia I don't know actually
oh what is that doing eating himself
hell don't eat yourself
it's got a nice texture to it I don't
know how to describe it it's quite soft
but still quite rigid which one did I
get
Bonsai honey what do you guys think
I'm gonna put him on the pickup truck
for now
yes you see this you just peel it
what is this strength plastic it has to
cut on it all right you just peel it
no tape required it's a nice figurine
but what that what is it
anime nerds tell me this is worth a
million sorry for my uncut nails
I'll put you here instead so you can see
all the stuff
disappointed
foreign
very satisfying opening what is this
now this is kind of cool
it's a little keychain of an angry man
thing mask I don't know
one out of five I got hania stage makeup
that expresses the terrible envy and
vengefulness of demonness which is
called Hanya we've all learned something
new today here one
can I at least get something cute for
Marzia I I think this could be it
I think she'll like this it's a sweater
a sweater keychain that's very Marty I
think she'll love it okay I'm happy five
out of five this is the best one we got
ourselves a winner you can get hats or
sweaters or bags it's a fun time oh they
didn't even try with it oh oh based tape
man whoever you are fellow Japanese man
thank you they folded the tape so I can
peel it off like a normal human being
thank you whatever this is plus 10. it's
a salt shaker thing will it actually
have salt inside what is this one no
it's not salt it's Chinese spices
so you could have gotten like basil
cardamom nutmeg
I doesn't actually have it sometimes
they actually do it like it's so low
keychain where you can add salt to your
meal I guess that's probably some legal
thing yeah it's still five out of five
for me
this one I've seen these are cool it's
those uh things you use to spray like
little model kits or paint hey I got a
good one too zero one nice could that be
a secret one
I love these very aesthetic at least for
uh gun Plumbing over here that's cool I
like this one uh four out of five yes
okay I saw this one you can get money
hell yeah that's dope give me the money
I hope I get a 10 uh ten thousand dollar
bill dollar really I did Japan Ginkgo
oh it's a towel it's a hand towel
it's hideous
I love it so in Japan they cut off all
like those Air Dryer machines in the
toilets and they don't give you paper
either so you're expected to bring your
own hand towel when you're in Japan uh
it's just to prevent disease obviously
and I don't mind it yeah I will bring
that feel like I'm extra cool
all right we got
a battle
that's it
not bad not bad I don't want it but it's
not bad two out of five oh I got the
rare one I get the rare one
look at these they're all clicky buttons
which I would have preferred but I got
the battle which is rare all right make
me an offer nft nerds how much you want
for it I will settle for no less than a
million this is a fun one I remember
this this is uh animals peeing in your
neural urinals which one am I going to
get I can't wait
I got the pig
I actually like it
that's not bad
that's probably my favorite one so far
4.5 out of 5. I had to retract for the
tape I have so many left to open I need
to hurry up okay what is this it says uh
Kinko a safe
oh it has a battery
a bank all right I got my ID card
why yes
this one's dope five out of five I like
that I like that a lot it has no purpose
but but then
Ace all right I changed it to a little
more appealing Angle now you can feel
like you're talking down to me
I'm so sorry it wasn't my fault
I had to poop in the shower God damn
there's tape all the way around there
sociopath taped this one down
they place the price for the gotcha
because they all vary a lot and they
place them kind of like underneath so
you won't see the price until you're
already trying to put money into the
machine which is you know a little
sketchy and I don't appreciate it and
here's a wolf playing guitar I will rate
it uh I'll rate it one for the furries
otherwise it would have been zero oh
this is cool and what the [ __ ] is this I
actually don't know if it's cool I lost
a lot of money because I didn't check
inside you can kind of like you kind of
have to look behind it to see if it's
actually full or not a lot of them were
empty so I entered my money I screw it
and if you screwed it all the way you
won't get your money back but if you
don't screw you can click the button to
get money back I screw so never screw
until you get money back what the hell
is this this is the worst one this one
sucks I hate it zero I guess it's like a
sign it says something about
construction I can't even make it stand
oh that's a zero
I'm very underwhelmed I usually get cool
gotcha there's got to be good ones in
here what look what tape man then this
is the opening I cracked the whole back
side open tape man
what is this
it's a Spaghetti Monster
10 out of 10. I love him that's actually
the one I wanted there's a soba monster
Ramen monster Curry monster
but I got spaghetti monster what did you
get today nothing you got nothing
oh this is cool it's a green tea vending
machine I got the green tea version
there's also the Coca-Cola version
I love all the copyrighted names
[Music]
I love it
that's satisfying I like it
[Music]
I like it that one's cool yeah that's a
five I like that one apparently if they
do any sort of like
little thing you don't expect I'm like
wow
oh okay I got a plane station for let's
go it's a PlayStation 4 guys and I got
the controllers for it too
wow
so cool
uh I don't like him
it's outdated I guess some stuff is cool
if you have all of them maybe I don't
know I'm not impressed
which one did I get I actually want this
one [ __ ] I wanted Luffy's hat
but I think I got this one I'm only on
episode 80 or something
so I don't know all the references or
new character this is nice uh plastic
actually nice quality okay spoilers
there will be a character named UT one
I'm starting to think maybe spending
money on gacha is not really worth it
I take it back it's a squishy hamster
I love it
it's the best
five out of five
oh
I'm about a third way through Jesus
Christ why do I buy so many oh I'm gonna
need eggy for this one
these are for cats it's a little hat uh
like a nurse hat he's not at the minute
so when he comes back I will give him a
hat no
no
I got it again [ __ ] I really wanted
Luffy's hat apparently that I bought it
twice and I still got UTA
God damn it
now there's two of them
another one to the climbing wall
climbing wall is so big climbing most of
strong add another Giza in there there
you go yes
yes oh it's so cute holy [ __ ] so tiny
this is from one of Marissa's favorite
anime I don't remember what it's called
because I never watched it but I know
the main character has this hat right
demented little demon
how's that
yes five out of five easy five out of
five
oh my God the whole thing just shattered
Jesus
ow could have been dangerous this is
huge oh my God this is gonna take
forever to build
it's a subway train so far yay
all right I've been building this for
the past 20 minutes I hate it it doesn't
work
it sucks one oh mindset you got to see
this
[Applause]
and then we have eggy
it's got a little head as well I start
anyone that's trick
kangoshi eggs
yeah you're a little fatigue sorry
loves it let's try it on Maya oh my God
she's adorable
that's fine out of five as well
oh you're so gentle today are you a
little sleepy all right I'll let you go
all right check this out it's a safe
you scan your card
but that's my favorite there's also this
oh you'll love this check this out is it
the vending machine
[Music]
I like that one uh there's also this
[Music]
that's only best no
[Music]
yeah oh
okay
[Music]
what
hopefully there's better ones in here
because I'm not super this
I did like this one too
I'm not super impressed so far
oh yes
girls get cute hamsters boy skates
propane tanks let's go this is what I
wanted hopefully it doesn't take an hour
to assemble this is for when you really
want to impress the boys
you show them nice
10 out of 10 love it actually it's four
out of five it doesn't make an annoying
sound so what's the point
what so there was a bunch of items and
I'm like what's the big deal and then
they have like snipers inside them
what happened you're not gonna snipe
anyone with that that would have been
cool I feel like it's me when I wake up
no way the opposite anyway that was cool
I like that
um four out of five what is this
oh okay so mindset a lot I mean it's it
is cool but she has that carpet in her
uh wardrobe exactly that one so I was
trying to get a miniature version which
would have been cool I'll probably try
for that again but instead we got the
panda version unfortunately right
zero out of five sorry I didn't realize
that carpet was so popular this looks
like something marched I bought yes it
is Martha was helping me because it took
so long to buy all the stuff so she had
to give her money oh this is cute so you
put the Eyes on yourself I think Marcy
wants to do that so I'll let her do that
I think you're supposed to put like a
little candle or something I don't know
they're supposed to like glow in the
dark the girls get the cute baby
the boys
what is it
yes
five out of five it's just they had a
bunch of different buttons or levers
and I gotta say
it's kind of satisfying
[Applause]
I like it five out of five
let's go looks like oh it's huge
something I have to reassemble bro you
ain't flying nowhere I mean those bad
boys
I don't get it
yeah two out of five it's kind of big
I keep breaking the whole thing open so
these are a bunch of animals looking in
the mirror
and I got a panda
filling in his eye lashes thing
Janet okay
uh that's kind of cool
two out of five what his names did March
here buy this she definitely did okay
Mista James is what I got
Mista James oh Mr James I like it more
now three out of five oh
we bought this before there are tiny
pugs in different things
we got the money at one oh that's so
cute I love it
five out of five love it they have a
bunch of ones we have uh this one as
well
so in Japan they have these loud and
obnoxious trucks that go through
neighborhoods especially like popular
ones and it's just to advertise
different artists and different bands
and I gotta be honest they just make me
never want to listen to them because
they're so loud and so annoying and oh
that's cool it lits up I love it five
out of five I like that one there's like
no space left and I have so many more oh
my God the packaging on this one
that's a cool gotcha though is this the
gacha no it opens it's a gacha gotcha
Pond I mean
how do I assemble it also the balls go
inside okay oh that's smart okay I'm
starting to get it
so these go inside eh
we close it
okay and then this goes here and then
I'm supposed to spin
[Laughter]
pull them on the back here that's kind
of that's not bad I like that I'm
keeping that camera battery running low
I've been here an hour I'm if there's
any more building I ain't doing it I get
to pick which game I want to play and
Destiny or and Destiny okay it's a
little mini arcade and you play and
Destiny it and I think yeah they come
out
that's kind of fun I feel like if you
had an arcade and then you have the
miniature version of the arcade that's
like a fun little thing other than that
I don't really care and Destiny and more
like and myself
another one and it has to be wrapped in
extra plastic that's how you know you're
in Japan put plastic around plastic and
then more this is just a gift for marzy
at this point
and then some tape over that
oh damn it I don't know if you guys have
watched Haiku it's a really good anime
there's so many anime related gotcha and
I saw haikyu and I was like I'll give it
a go
I got the chess character I don't know
what to tell you guys
oh we know I like him he's the bull guy
my bad uh hiki fence don't cancel me I
love this guy I don't remember his name
that's cool all right one out of five
so the gotcha itself just like the
Mickey one is the gotcha I feel like I'm
saying gotcha a lot
and it's a little mini Lottery oh my
[ __ ] God I'm supposed to build all
this uh for the sake of my battery
running out I'll build it in the end and
then I'll show it in the end oh my God
my favorite thing in the whole world
Jello I hate jello
zero what is these
it opens oh they're so [ __ ] cool I
love this one no [ __ ] way dude sorry
Grand Seiko you're done so you're you're
grand dying ton so good joke it's a
watch dude and look at this I hit the
open button it tells me the time it
tells me mother flipping time and [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] that is so cool
it's for babies but I love it yes
yes was the time hey let me tell you
it's 12 it's definitely not 12. oh okay
there's a button on the side I can set
it that is dope
love it
600 out of 100 that was the best one by
far I love that sometimes you strike
gold that's how the guy should God's
work what were my options by the way I
could have gotten a Playstation One a
Sega Saturn or a Sega Saturn or a
PlayStation
I gotta buff hamster in a swimming thing
I hope everyone is as impressed as I am
oh so Martin never played this game did
you guys ever play this game she didn't
have a childhood damn it
it's that game where you put swords in
the barrel and then the guy pops up I
think but a mini miniature version that
that will I will have to build that in a
minute I'm putting all the build stuff
on the side and then I'll do that this
is gonna be a six timer yes another goal
another gold guys this one was cheap it
was like 200 200 yen I was surprised
it's not a Tamagotchi it looks like a
tamaguchi this explains the price why it
was so cheap
and what's the point
God damn it zero I'm losing my mind here
guys what is this Final Fantasy stuff
the mindset was about this
Final Fantasy anyone
I think it is I never actually played
Final Fantasy I was a Nintendo 64 boy
growing up what is this
it's frogs on top of
different fungus
help me I am in Hell press like And
subscribe and I will be able to leave
right now
released me from this prison of pain
please
I don't want to build more build more
damn it
the toilet though
toilet
so some people think Japan gets very hot
[Music]
it's too strong
it does nothing
there we go that's better
uh
I guess that's cool it's a miniature
pancake
and a miniature packaging for the
pancake I could have gotten bread damn
it I got the lamest one dude I could
have gotten bright
I could have gone bread
[Applause]
what is this what is this you can't even
see anything I do anymore what is this
it's got a light on his butt I know it
lights up how does it lit up
oh okay I got the bad one I know Marzia
loves this guy
how did it lit up though it definitely
has something in his anus I just don't
know how to activate the anus I think I
got a broken one
all right zero even the panda is dying
of Shame I'm reaching towards the end
right now no more Bill oh my God what is
this
zookeepers lion saint
no
I'm just gonna say no to that not even
worth unboxing
canned Mandarin oranges
it's metal
um sure is it over no I definitely saw
someone escaping ah here we go
what that is cute it's a mini notebook
does it actually open it does
oh yeah that's kind of cute I like that
uh this is a Jujitsu Kaizen one it
actually looks cool high grade real
figure okay oh my God what a mess
Felix I am a minimalist also Felix we're
taking a break there and then I build
this stuff
wow we sure have been recording for a
while how I wonder what time it is
all right so I built this one this is a
Kaizen it's a nice quality figure but
obviously no one wants this one I think
that's what I've learned about gotcha
here today is that you should really
just get it if you see something that
you want I just feel like I have a bunch
of instructions me speaking of which
portapani I built it
are you not entertained oh you're not
entertained
who should I put in there I guess I
could put the put the urinal Peg inside
that's kind of funny look he's pissing
on you
uh maybe you could have money in there
honestly I don't think anyone's gonna
come looking in your porta potty porta
potty this took forever I haven't tried
it yet
so
oh my God it was open I spilled it all
over
ah why does it keep spilling it's black
[Applause]
I wanted to play it with Mercy I spent
so much time building it
that's fine
that's life anyway
minivan
I'm losing my mind here guys
bread I got the bread
yes this is the one it's so soft
oh wow Japan has so soft bread it's so
squishy
incredible I love it and I get an extra
slice
[Applause]
extra slimes of bran never know when
needed
with that tiny look for that they always
you know that bay that no one ever uses
get out of here you take it and you spin
it and then you're done come on I think
I only have three left
I wanted to play bingo in Mars again
can't believe it oh this one's cool it's
a little tissue box a portable see what
I mean with the salt and pepper I was
like why does he not have it no it's a
mini trash bag
no [ __ ] way no way
yes
that is genius I would buy this I always
feel like I need it because in Japan you
need to carry your own trash because
there's no trash bags and I always feel
like I need to carry one I love that I'm
definitely oh I'm so mad I broke it five
out of five that's brilliant all right
did it
that was awful uh
which one's one of the best that's what
you came here for if you made it to the
end congratulations uh we started off
strong
we did have the Bell
that was cool we do have the fan as well
I think all right my favorite is
definitely the watch because that's dope
I did also really like the safety box
just because of how completely redundant
and useless it is
but it still has a function
like me
I also really
like with the paint oh I forgot to show
you guys uh the Pirate game I don't know
if you guys ever played this one it's
kind of like uh I had the crocodile
version as well
it was fun as a kid and not gonna lie
hey it's kind of fun it works it's a fun
idea I love the hatch
the hats were definitely a winner
oh and the vending machine was cool too
it's always cool with like
and the glowy truck still going strong
[Music]